- I always say chemistry is everything.
Because if everything
went smoothly all the time
we'd be very complacent
and we'd stay in one place.
One day at a time, one hour at a time,
don't get overwhelmed.
You always hear that phrase
"hard work beats talent,
but talent don't work hard".
Nobody knows what you can do but you.
We work really hard.
We have a great show.
Let's just have fun.
Create something of quality
that is really going to
make a difference in the marketplace.
We're all extraordinary.
Nobody's the same.
I cannot tell you how many people
tried to talk me out of that.
Like please don't do this.
You reach, reach way beyond way beyond
and even if you fall,
you still got so far.
She's an American actress, author,
dancer, fashion designer, and singer.
She's the first Latina actress
to earn over a million dollars
for her roll in "Out of Sight".
She's regarded as the most influential
Hispanic artists in the United States.
She's Jennifer Lopez
and here are her top
ten rules for success.
(swish bang)
At the end of the day with an entrepreur
you're talkin about a creative visionary.
You're talkin about
somebody whose the impetus,
whose the spark...
To the business, to everything.
And then you're smart
enough to grab this person
whose great at marketing,
with this person whose great at
all the different aspects
of what you'll need to make
whatever it is your
business is to succeed.
I always say chemistry is everything.
You have to find chemistry with people
and the people you have chemistry with
doesn't always work.
That first person that
you choose for that job
is like "Uh, this not going to work".
(laughing)
But then there's the people that come in
and you just, you're like "Wow".
Stuff happens when we're together.
And I've been lucky enough
to have a lot of people
like that in my life.
And because I'm a Leo and I'm very loyal,
I stay with those people
and we're able to build
and build and build
and think and create, and discover
and keep challenging ourselves
to be better and better and better.
And what other produce could we create?
What other thing can we do
for the audience that's watching?
Well, Luana, there's been
many mistakes I've made.
I think that you only
learn, really, in this world
from the mistakes you
make, from hard times,
from going through difficult periods -
that's when you grow.
And we should look at these moments
as opportunities for growth
and as almost blessings.
Because if everything went
smoothly all the time,
we'd be very complacent
and we'd stay in one place.
And we'd never, ever stretch ourselves
or question ourselves
or want to be better
people in a certain way.
But these moments, they
force us to do these things.
And those mistakes that I made,
I can't just mention one mistake, I think
of so many things that
through my life that I go
"Uh, that one maybe was
not the right thing to do."
But, if I hadn't of done that,
then I wouldn't have known it
wasn't the right thing to do.
And so, those things are necessary.
I love what I do.
And I feel really blessed.
And I always try to remember that.
Because, like you said
when I walked in here,
You like "Ah, you have so much going on,
so busy and everything",
but the truth is like I told you,
what I'm doing downstairs with Kohl's
is something I love doing.
And that's my thing
and it's like, how do I make this work?
[Jennifer Lopez] How
do we figure that out?
And how do I give my best to that
and to everything I'm doing?
And it's just one day at a time,
one hour at a time.
Don't get overwhelmed.
It's not rocket science.
I'm not curing cancer.
I'm just entertaining.
Hard work, I think, is
the most important thing.
You always hear that phrase
"hard work beats talent,
but talent don't work hard".
It's good if you have both.
(laughing)
And I believe everybody does have talent.
You got to find your talent and
then you got to work really, really hard.
And I just strive to be the best.
And I think those are the
biggest key to success.
But, the biggest one
of all is working hard.
You can't accomplish anything
if you're not in early and out the latest,
which, I usually am.
Nobody knows what you can do but you.
Nobody can tell you.
If I tell you all the people who
told me I wasn't going to act
or sing, or dance,
or I wasn't good at it,
or that I should stop,
or I should quit, or even
after I became famous,
you know, for doing these things,
I would be locked in a house
somewhere doing nothing.
The truth is nobody
knows what inside of you.
Only you know what's inside of you.
Only you know what you can accomplish
and what you're capable of
and what your gut and your dreams
and your desires, and your wants,
and your ability.
You only know.
Nobody else knows.
So, whatever you feel in
your heart and your gut,
you should follow that.
Follow that.
And then if that changes one day,
that's fine, too.
And then, you follow that.
But you're the only one who knows.
Nobody else.
[Interviewer] In Montreal,
- Yes.
[Interviewer] minutes before
you're offstage ready to go on,
[Jennifer Lopez] Yeah.
- Where's that energy level,
what's going through your mind?
- Oh, wow. Tons of adrenaline,
but, it's funny right before a show,
in the hours before a
show, you know it's coming.
That hour before, you get that adrenaline
and you get ready to go.
But, for me, in the
minutes, in the seconds
before the show starts,
I get very, very calm.
It's like everything goes whoooosh.
- But this is the first solo.
This is ...
- Yeah, but it's fun.
And, you know I have Enrique with me.
I did the solo stuff in South American
so, that first night in Panama,
for me, was a bit nerve-racking.
It was so funny.
We taped our prayer backstage
and after the prayer, I was like,
we work really hard.
We have a great show.
Let's just have fun.
I had to remind myself.
As much work as it is,
and as much as I want to do well,
and as much as everybody
there wants to do their best,
and be successful;
At the end of the day, those
people are there to have fun.
You have fun. They have fun.
It's a successful night.
And so, that's what we do.
- How do you stay, how
do you pick what is next?
How do you just know that feeling where...
- I think it is kind of a feeling.
But it's also a
dedication
to creating
one, a high quality product.
Something that's authentic to you
and your brand, which is I think,
the most important thing.
And something that is
a differentiate of your product as well.
Something that is only specific
and not everybody else is doing it
in the same way you're doing it.
How do you differentiate
that authentic product of high quality?
Do you know what I mean?
It's a combination of those things.
And again, my team would
constantly challenging ourselves,
whether it's movies, or brands,
or TV, or books, or music,
or whatever it is to
create something of quality
that is really going to make a
difference in the marketplace.
When did I feel like I went
from ordinary to extraordinary?
I have to tell you that I
always felt, from my parents,
that you could achieve anything
so long as you worked hard.
They were all about hard work
and being able to accomplish
whatever it is that you
wanted to accomplish.
That was the idea that was
put in my head very young.
I like when they ask me what
would you want to be up there
and they gave me a
choice of all these words
and I said be extraordinary,
because, I feel like
we're all extraordinary.
Nobody's the same.
There's no two people that are alike.
And honestly, we all have the capacity,
and we all have it in us,
the ability to do whatever
it is that we want to do.
And all we have to do is kind of
just put our minds to
it and just work hard
and you can make anything happen.
For me was never about
money and stuff like that.
The last time I did something crazy.
- [Interviewer] Was it going
to Idol to do that thing?
- I thing that was a big, absolutely.
I cannot tell you how many people
tried to talk me out of that.
Like "Please don't do this".
"This is the worst move
you could ever make".
And I was like, you know what?
I don't think so.
It feels right for my life right now.
I had just had the babies.
They were just startin to walk and talk
and really become fully functional people.
And I just thought, you know what?
They need stability.
We've been traveling around.
At that time Marc, their dad,
was touring a lot.
And I was traveling,
and it was just like, you know what?
This is going to be a good thing for them,
for me, I love the show, and
I just basically said to everybody,
I kind of overrode it.
I have to say Benny
was kind of on my side.
He was like, "What do you
feel like in your gut?
"I feel like business-wise,
for these reasons,
"it could be good.
"But, you have to feel good about it."
And I said I feel like it's
going to be a good thing.
I feel like I have
something to contribute.
I love music.
I love talking about music.
I love artists.
That's what I want.
I think this could be a really nice thing.
By the way, we only
signed off for one year.
You know, it wasn't like
a thing where I thought,
Oh God, I'm going to be here forever.
I said no, I'll do it for a year
and we'll see what happens.
I wound up loving it so much
that I did it for two years.
And they asked me back, I was like okay.
Taking risks, for me, has
been a big part of my journey.
Just thinking outside the box,
doing the thing that
everybody thinks is dangerous sometimes,
and just knowing that you can do it,
knowing that you'll get through it.
Thinking big.
It's something I say a lot
of times when I feel bored.
I always encourage my fans to think big.
Think as big as you can.
You reach, reach way beyond
and even if you fall,
you've still gone so far.
Short on your goal, you
still have went so high.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know which of J-Lo's
top ten rules meant the most to you,
had the biggest impact.
Leave it in the comments below
and we will join in the discussion.
- And tell us who your
favorite entrepreneur is
that you want Evan to
feature in a future video.
Leave it in the comments below.
- Thank you guys for watching.
Continue to believe.
And we'll see you soon.